driving out of kiev the trail of
destruction is endless
this was the main road for the russian
advance towards the capital
burnt out buildings cars and businesses
lives in tatters this bridge in european
came to symbolize the flight of people
under shelling
olena pirohova was among them it's her
first day back and it's overwhelming
just came to
to see what happened to
my dream
and i constantly
but we're
alive is the most important for all of
us
and ukraine will survive
we will survive
we will revive all this
the bowling alley she owned was on the
front line she shows us the video of the
battlefield that was around it
along the road you can see where the
fiercest fighting took place this used
to be a cultural center it will take
weeks before all this rubble is removed
but the full extent of what happened
here is something that's still being
discovered on a daily basis
more than two weeks after the last
russian tank left the town of borodyanka
is still coming to terms with its losses
bodies hastily buried are being exhumed
this woman finally found her son and his
best friend believed to have been killed
in the early days of the war
the third body is of a teenage girl who
still remains unclaimed
burujanka was hit particularly hard
eighty percent of the buildings and
houses in the town and surrounding
villages are either totally or partially
damaged
finding ways to get it back on its feet
is a monumental task for mayor giorgi
yerko
he has set up shop in the local school
because his office was also reduced to
rubble
we need to get the government
institutions back and find new places to
operate from
we have to restore electricity gas and
water
experts
we still don't know which buildings will
be demolished or repaired
many people don't want to live in the
old buildings anymore
a few streets away valentina is sifting
through the remains of her house
her family had lived here for
generations they spent a month cramped
in the basement
only to come out and find the memories
of a lifetime gone
sure
i am demoralized i give in they were
shooting at girls raping girls people i
know
i also know people who were executed
with their hands tied up
after all this how do you want me to
find the strength to rebuild my house
with the fighting still going on it's
difficult to put a price tag on
reconstruction
the eu estimates it will be in the
hundreds of billions of dollars but for
the people here no money will be enough
to fill the sense of loss
of hamid al jazeera on the road north of
kiev